galaine maxwell's sex trafficking trial
began this week in new york and at the
end of day two we heard from one of
jeffrey epstein's female victims as well
as his former pilot gillian maxwell as
you know is charged with recruiting
underage girls for epstein and
participating in some of his abuse of
the girls i want to bring in now
bloomberg news legal team editor and
team leader katya porzikonsiki who has
been following this trial from the very
beginning when they began selecting the
jury katya thanks so much for for
speaking with us um i want to take a
step back for a moment here and just
talk to you about
the framing of this trial because
opening arguments were yesterday that's
done witnesses are now testifying what's
the narrative that the prosecution has
laid out and what's the narrative that
the defense has laid out
absolutely so the prosecutors um are
going to be calling uh four
alleged victims who are going to paint
the picture of
gillane maxwell's role in their abuse
that took over um that that was from
decades ago um but that you know they
say have you know permanently altered
their lives um and they are going to um
basically talk about how she helped in
in bringing and sourcing girls for uh
jeffrey epstein and grooming them for
abuse uh which which take took many
different forms uh for for the different
the different uh women who were then
girls um you know whether it was paying
for their school or or um being some
sort of a role model or social sort of
source of support if they had sometimes
um you know like volatile lives uh it
was all part of a grooming process and
that's what uh what they are um alleging
and there are six counts against her um
and
uh the steepest one would carry a
sentence of 40 years and she's found
guilty of that okay gotcha so that's the
prosecution's version or the story that
they're going to tell
with the help of these four female
victims as witnesses how's the defense
countering this what is the defense
saying about what elaine maxwell did or
didn't do
so the defense um had
went right for it uh yesterday in their
opening statement basically saying that
what we're going to hear is is
basically memories that are are wrong um
and uh and that delane uh didn't have
that uh didn't have that role that she
is a scapegoat for jeffrey epstein
um
that the that basically because jeffrey
epstein has committed suicide there's no
one else to blame and so they're going
after elaine maxwell who
was a ex-girlfriend of his and a
property manager of his and um and
basically she's as the as the attorney
for her maxwell said yesterday she's
filling an empty seat
um
so which is which is an interesting
argument also because you know she is a
woman and she's the first woman to go to
trial in the metoo era um or the in the
post the 22 era so uh it's an
interesting um
question for
for uh for a juror to face um given that
mostly it's men in this position yeah i
think that's a really important point
and it's notable here that the defendant
is a woman the prosecutor is a woman uh
the defendant's lead lawyer is a woman
as well and you have these four women
who will be called up as witnesses
they're victims they're all women and
the judge is a woman as well we can get
to that in a moment here but um i want
to talk about what happened today on day
two of the trial because uh the former
pilot of jeffrey epstein his former
private jet pilot testified today and i
know a lot's gonna be made of the fact
that he name-checked a whole bunch of
celebrities like chris tucker the
comedian kevin spacey the actor
bill clinton and donald trump the former
presidents all that's interesting and
i'm sure it's going to make all the
different tabloids but what did we
actually learn from this former pilot
what did we learn from his testimony
so um the pilot worked for jeffrey
epstein for almost 30 years uh piloting
him around and um saw many many people
entered the jet um over the course of
that time and basically you know
he's testified over the course of two
days and this on the first day he was
basically saying well you know this is
uh it's easier to fly private um a lot
less hassle so a lot of people like to
fly private so people would hitch ride
on jeffrey epstein's jets um and then
you know that's kind of what sets up him
seeing a lot of these famous people um
and you know
again these names that have been dropped
are not new they've been released you
know in depositions over the years um
but
the inter the key point of his presence
on the stand
was to basically say that he saw with
his own eyes one of the victims on that
jet um and that is uh
jane is her pseudonym um the women are
going by pseudonyms um and and
saw her uh when he
she was given like a tour of the jet and
he noticed her
um she had bright blue eyes she appeared
mature to his to his uh knowledge there
were he never saw women under the age of
what he expected with or thought was 20
on on board um but that woman
prosecutors say had been groomed but and
actually abused by allegedly by jeffrey
epstein and delane maxwell starting from
the age of 14
where they approached her um
at her art camp
and interlochen
and uh and indeed the
the pilot also did confirm that he flew
the jet at one point to
um the nearest airport to interlock in
uh to pick up luggage
but it's
so there are there are pieces there that
um are kind of painting a picture uh but
the the cro on cross exam they they
basically asked him you know like what
did you see did you see any wrong doing
and um
and he said that he never saw any
females who appeared to be under the age
of 20 during the three decades that he
piloted the planes nor any illegal
activity aboard when he'd leave the
cockpit to use the restroom so um
so it's it's but it's a visual you know
confirmation that that that victim was
there under epstein's watch um and then
the the
government gave um a list of birth
certificates um and flight records to
the jury uh presumably to show them the
age of that witness um to say yeah she
was underage okay so it's to place the
fact that the victim was on the jet even
though the pilot himself said that uh
the door between the cockpit and the
rest of the private jet was always
closed so he didn't actually see
anything even if there was something to
see or even if there wasn't anything to
see um you had mentioned jeffrey epstein
killed himself while he was in prison he
was awaiting trial at the time so he
never really had to face the music here
and so galaine maxwell's attorneys have
argued that she's kind of a convenient
stand-in a scapegoat because he's not
able to um be accountable held
accountable for what
is is
being alleged of him so how much does
his shadow loom over this trial i mean
are people saying his name constantly i
assume they are but how much
deliberation is there when it comes to
him
versus uh galen maxwell is it really a
trial about him or is it really about
her
well i mean his shadow looms large i
mean in so much of the testimony today
including right now we have um jane that
minor victim she she's testifying as
well today um and has been for the last
couple hours and
it's a lot about the abuse that he
that that he committed and
um it's heavy i mean it's really dark uh
the allegations that she that she makes
especially given how young she was um
and and the role that he played in kind
of giving her
uh an apartment um and and giving her
schooling um and it's all a part of the
grooming process um uh and that's that's
where maxwell comes in and she did
describe that maxwell um was present
when he would abuse her um to give her a
sense of oh this is fine this is normal
i'm right here
and that's you know so epstein's
role in the crimes is massive but the
but it sets the stage to ask well what
was maxwell's role in those crimes and
that's what the point of the trial is
so she has been um detained and she's
been in prison for months now um we've
we're seeing her in court
what do the reporters who are at the
courthouse every day you are editing
their stories you're constantly in
communication with them what are they
saying about how gillian maxwell
presents what is she like what's her
body language like during during these
testimonies
um it seems like she's been pretty
reserved and quiet um at least that's
what uh it's that's what it sounds like
she hugs her attorneys um when she gets
into court and when she leaves at the
end
um
and uh
and so but so far there's been
you know
looking at the jury uh or um looking at
the victims and but not not a lot to say
about her demeanor so far she's been
pretty composed there hasn't much to say
there hasn't been anything to write
about what she's been doing
and i'm sure that's the way that her
defense attorney wants it too um i
mentioned earlier how this is it feels
like an all-women trial female judge
female defendant female prosecutor four
female witnesses one of whom already
testified today what do we know about
the jury you were there at the beginning
when the
attorneys were picking the juries um
what can you tell us about the jury and
how they are responding to
this uh very female dominated trial
well we have no idea what they're
thinking um but the jury uh is a
fairly
good representation of new yorkers it
sounds like from their bios we were able
to piece together from transcripts um
what they do for a living um you know
what their general demographics are um
how exposed they had been to this trial
or to the to the characters before um
which was really interesting because
it kind of made a point like where are
you going to find people that have never
heard of jeffrey epstein exactly
for this trial but they did i mean i
mean they didn't find people that have
never heard of jeffrey epstein but a lot
of them were like oh i flipped the
channel like i saw something but i
flipped the channel you know we've got
home health aides we've got government
workers um
like an advertising guy and and in terms
of their their gender makeup we don't
have that confirmed yet um but it's a
it's it's it seems like a pretty uh
balanced representation um
and actually one of the jurors got
excused today
because he had a surprise christmas
vacation planned um and so last minute
they had to change out a jury a juror um
uh which you know everyone was probably
cursing at the sky that this one person
got to leave and enjoy his holidays
no kidding exactly especially since
we're only at the beginning of this
trial very quickly as we wrap up here
katya what are you looking for in the
coming days what do you think you guys
will be writing on as kind of the
sidebar to what else is happening day in
and day out through this trial
um i i think
what i'm very interested in is is the
you know just exactly painting the
picture of their of their environment
and who was in there and you know who
the witnesses are like we have no idea
who the witnesses in this trial are
going to be which is really interesting
because sometimes you get a witness list
but in this case it's sealed so it's
actually a surprise like almost every
time um so it'll be really interesting
to see who's coming to speak obviously
we're gonna have the four women in total
speak but then all the women all any any
people that that saw them um
uh we never know you know
it's unlikely that they're going to be
any surprises in terms of name drops but
it could be that there are some
surprises in terms of you know what
those people did or saw um and i and the
um and i think we'll
hopefully i mean we'll probably hear
from more um for more women uh who who
may might not be one of the minor
victims but might be
called to corroborate or to explain a
little bit more or give credibility to
those women so um it's going to be a
really interesting trial um it's a you
know window into a a very
seedy underbelly of you know manhattan
wealth and florida wealth um and and so
i think that's why there's so much
interest in this case uh given that you
know it seemed to have happened right in
front of a lot of people's faces and a
lot of those people are famous people
yeah definitely feels like it could be
something that was um made up for hbo
max or or netflix um if it weren't for
the fact that it's true katya thank you
so much katya porzikonsky bloomberg news
legal team leader and editor really
appreciate you joining us